CHRISTINA TOSI: And I was raised by this
funny mom that loved to make box cake,
and I was raised by grandmothers.
And they made frosting one
way, and honestly, that
is the way that we make frosting today.
We don't make boiled frosting, we don't
make anything other than this frosting.
And it's really simple and it's really
easy to alter the flavors of it.
It's butter, unsalted
European-style butter.
It's confectioners sugar.
We paddle those two suckers together
until the butter has broken down.
We're going to make this
frosting into coffee frosting.
When we are creating recipes and we're
trying to figure out what we want,
what flavor we want and what
vehicle-- so in this case coffee
into a frosting-- we have so many
decisions we have to think about.
One, what kind of what type of
frosting do we want to make?
Inevitably, it comes back to this
very simple style of frosting.
And how are we going
to get the flavor in?
So when you think about coffee,
it's like, OK, we can do this.
I could skin this cat
so many different ways.
I can just add coffee, but
coffee is largely water-based,
so it's going to all alter my volume.
It's going to plummet.
JENNA: It's going to
plummet the volume fraction.
CHRISTINA TOSI: It's not
good, it's going to separate,
it's not going to emulsify.
It's not good, no one wants
an unemulsified frosting.
Would you hand me one more spatula?
JENNA: Yeah, of course.
CHRISTINA TOSI: I can add espresso.
Espresso works.
Espresso is a little bit
bitter, and I don't know,
I don't want it to taste like espresso.
I want it to taste like coffee.
What else could I do?
I could melt the butter and
try and brew coffee through it,
or try to do a pour over with coffee.
I start going in all these places,
of like OK, how can I do it?
We tested so many different
recipes for coffee frosting,
and we ended up taking whole milk,
instant coffee, and some kosher salt.
The instant coffee really allows you
to get a depth of flavor in there
without having to add too much milk.
So you can really, really
control the depth of flavor
against the amount of milk
that you're adding in.
The hardest part about
creating something
is it's really easy to dream up
an idea, but it's really hard
to make it into a reality.
And the hardest part about
something like this coffee frosting
is I know I need to add
coffee in some in some degree.
The instant coffee really needs
the milk to dissolve itself.
We don't-- I mean, maybe some of you eat
instant coffee granules-- but I don't.
I want it to be smooth, and I want
it to have the flavor of coffee.
I can't just paddle instant
coffee into my butter.
I need enough liquid to hydrate that
instant coffee into a coffee flavor.
But I also know that I only
have a certain allowance
for the amount of liquid that I can
add into this frosting before it breaks
and it separates.
And this coffee frosting
literally comes right up
to the line in terms of keeping
that emulsification intact
and separating it out.
And that is the hardest
part of the job, where
it's like knowing when to say when.
I wish that more of
us took these classes
to be able to really calculate
the math and understand.
We understand why it's happening and
we understand how it's happening,
but sometimes we don't understand what
the very, very, very, very, very--
what the tipping point
is, and what amount
we can add before it
tips over and so on.
And that's the coolest
part of the job, too.
It's sort of getting to learn about the
scientific process through something
as simple as, all right, I
want to make a coffee frosting,
but it needs to be able to
be smooth enough to spread.